hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the very last time
and I've said this before that I will
play vanish I am through with people
saying that I didn't actually beat the
game though I kinda did I was right
there at the end there was only a little
sequence to go and I don't want to hear
any more of this oh you're a big whiny
baby no I'm gonna finish it and I'm
gonna finish it so good that you guys
are gonna never ever ever question again
my horror game playing abilities now
I've said before that this game scares
me but you know what I'm not even gonna
I'm not even gonna worry about it this
time because I am a professional gamer
and I need to be able to beat this like
I have to cuz otherwise I mean what's
supportive more what what is even the
point I am just a big bubble blowing
baby no one will watch my videos and
then I'll just have to retire from
YouTube so if I don't beat it I will
retire from YouTube in shame a lot of
people right I don't want that because
they know that I'm probably not gonna
beat it but that's besides the point I
am a man of my word
so I will beat it even though I probably
don't I'm actually on a time crunch
today so if I don't beat in like this is
actually kind of stressful if I don't
beat it and I hold my promise I will
have to quit YouTube and never ever ever
ever ever do it again
and I have like 20 minutes to do this
max I have 20 minutes so the game is on
and there's something already in my eye
we're in a great start I can already
tell oh my god my left eye gods in there
okay I think we're OK
okay I think we're good we're good let's
do this
eeny meeny miny moe no time oh yeah I
remember oh it's all coming back to me
now this game Dick's with V and by V I
mean me this game Dick's with me but oh
well walking down the corridor walking
along moving fast walking passing I'm
home but back up slowly back up slowly
changing direction changing my mind
going the other way now because I feel
like it there's no other
beside that I remember him every time I
load up this game I'm like nah I ain't
gonna give me this time and then I go
like oh this game dude always gave his
horrifying and it does not like you and
it wants you to poop your pants but I've
got this game by the balls because i
don't play with any pants on that is
like a requirement
mostly for other reasons other than it
gets hot in my room and i have to take
off all my clothes cuz it's getting hot
in her but it's cold down here in the
darkness oh come on this namby-pamby guy
is already quivering in fear dammit
there's that god damnit back away slowly
god there's no just they're just digging
with me now they're just digging with me
like it's not this isn't how it's
supposed to be you shut you mouth you
also shut your mouth I am I'm not ready
for this
no I'm ready for this but I ain't ready
to have all this happen if I could just
get to the generator room and then the
other place that I need to go in a quick
expeditious order then I would be very
happy okay there's a hidey hole for if I
need to run oh god I'm gonna have to
quit you to Barna this down is gonna go
oh the zelans gonna go I'm gonna be
quitting YouTube now why did I make a
step I'm such a douche hey let's go
let's go let's go let's make it
hopefully shut up you I barely took two
steps in this game let go straight
that's all let's always agree that the
the correct path is on the straight and
narrow that's that's what I've always
been told that's when my pop he always
told me back on the farm when we used to
graze turnips I don't know what I'm
talking about anymore well all I know is
that turn into hillbilly kind of it oh
well I was hanging out with cinnamon
toast can you know who's a bitter pill
okay I'm sorry I'm so sorry I'm sorry
everybody
I just get in these moods where I just
spout out whatever is in my mind and my
heart palpitations start a little
thumping a bit too much and then my
brain doesn't know what it's doing not
straight and narrow always straight and
narrow it'll never lead me astray even
though it's kind of leading me in the
journal darkness here I don't think it's
gonna be a problem I think I'm gonna be
okay
I think things are looking better sure
smells down here huh sir sorry those
okay can't go on the straight and narrow
anymore but that don't matter
cuz I don't need to go in the straight
and narrow I know the true path in my
mind shut up shut up come on generator
room generator room I have to admit I
have had the worst luck of anyone
playing this game I know I've seen other
people play this game to try to get
hints on how to beat it it's totally
randomized in everything for one and
number two like the random and owner of
generator has unfavorably dismissed me
as a player like it does not like me
because I know that there are many many
many many people that have played this
and have been able to get the generator
in a reasonable amount of time but me
not me cuz ask me right you know f me
that's exactly what it's gonna be and
that's what I'm gonna do so there we go
now I'm gonna run smack face into a
bunch of douches over there and I'm
never gonna ask straight narrow
straighten them okay maybe I'll go this
way
maybe straight narrow was not the proper
path I'm just saying you know something
in the back of my mind decided to change
my mind and now I'm gonna go this way
huh yay okay now if you're all
unfamiliar with this or you don't know
what's going on the reason I'm excited
to be here is because once you find this
place you get the glow stick but once
you find the other place after finding
this place you get the keys and then
it's all matter is just finding the exit
so I just got a
that always gets me I know that happens
I always know that happens and that
always still gets me okay so I got to
get out of glowstick cuz it's very dark
glow stick please glow stick please oh
that does not help that really does not
help all that does is put a green thing
by my head okay I hear a tunnel right
there so that's good good damn it but
we're good
oh we're good happy take Callooh Callay
ain't gonna get murdered today I'm so
excited why did I have to get the
generator room first if you get the
other room first you get a glow stick
there and then you get a key in the
generator room and then you wouldn't
have to walk in the darkness while
trying to find the other place oh well
though I guess it don't matter in the
end it doesn't even matter oh god I
cannot see a damn thing
everything is pitch-black to me if
there's a monster I wouldn't even see it
until it's 2 inches from my face
straight narrow Oh God
you see there's no difference there's no
difference between one shut your mouth
and go stuff it with bread okay okay
okay doing good doing good
I haven't even sprinted yet you shut
your mouth okay straight and narrow it
won't lead me astray I know where I'm
going
not really
that's the fake it's just random noise
nothing I need to be concerned about
god damn every time I go into this game
like I ain't gonna be me I played in a
bunch I know this cares but then I take
such long gaps in between it that I
forget light OH
light gone is that what's know that
which brings not new every time I think
I hear something and it's like as I knew
that from before but they haven't
updated the game in forever
these sends a vision fake its fake it's
not real has nothing to do with anything
that's actually in front of me right now
although there probably is something in
front of me right now probably I swear
to god this glow stick doesn't do a ding
dong damn thing and I hate it for it
I hate for it test balls an ass dipper
freakout err the strain arrow didn't do
me any justice no no no no no no no no
no no no no no there's the entrance
apparently okay now I can stop running
cuz I think he's not buying me anymore I
think I don't know maybe I'm not turning
around to find out
hello note on the wall okay cool
drain narrow by the way if you guys
didn't remember things change so if you
go one direction then you turn around go
another direction things will be totally
different from start to finish they'll
be totally different okay oh come on I
don't have the keys ah why I don't have
it you're taunting me you dude ah Maggie
hate you so much game oh I hate it it
won't let me win I've got one last try
or else I'll have to quit YouTube
YouTube my youtube career done that's it
that's the end of it if I can't beat it
I'm I'm a man of my word this is the end
of it it's the end of it those good run
almost two years good job everybody
whoo
I'm never I'm never gonna beat this mi
I'm never gonna beat this
I'm never gonna read this game no matter
how many times I come back this I am
never gonna beat it absolutely
ridiculous
okay okay straight narrow never led me
astray before in fact any direction that
I've went has always led me astray
shut up I do not want to hear any of it
Oh mmm-hmm No mmm that wall is pissing
on the ground over there
everything I'm in the sewers you got to
remember that I'm in the sewers so one
um I've got the pungent smell of fetid
feces in my nostrils and then there's
just rats everywhere probably and then
these mole men who probably just go to
the bathroom wherever there's god dammit
you're not there screw you and these
mole men who are douches by the way and
ugly too or just probably going to the
bathroom wherever they feel like it and
stepping in that and everything's bad
suing stupid in this game he's really
impressively well made but bad luck to
me apparently cuz that's how it works
cuz that's how it works cuz I can't get
a break I'll never be able to get a
break but I'm not bitter I'm not bitter
about anything I'm not bitter about the
hand that it's been dealt to me I am my
own man no I am a strong independent man
who don't need no man I don't know I'm
just going down the hallway shut up
don't listen to me
shop know what be fake
now you fake I know you're fake that's
not real I think that you're real but
you know who oh damn it I thought I saw
it I thought though I thought I was
entering an area that I was gonna
actually shut your mouth or else I'll
shut it for you I'll punch you right in
the GABA mate swear on me mum shut up I
didn't even pick up the note didn't even
need to didn't even want to that's a
dead end again huh that's too bad cuz
I'm going in here before you even notice
before you even know
I heard that whispering in my left ear
who's more left here now I persevered
through a lot before I've beaten scp-087
be the one with like that actually can
end if you go down to the bottom all the
way it just ends in death but just oh hi
it took two hours but I actually did
beat it so I have the perseverance
required to be this but in all honesty I
think I'm I think I've played this more
time overall than I actually have SPO
SMB no it's not
general writer the well thing I don't
know why you ever beiie okay now now I
ain't gonna do it okay not feeling that
either
nope not feeling it not feeling it it
ain't good it ain't good for my health
ain't good for my heart this guy only
have a set time limit because he'll just
keel over and die shut up oh god dammit
god dammit okay good good good good good
good good good running away now I can
already tell that my character is just
gonna keel over and give up at any
moment here and I'm gonna have to start
all over and I haven't made any progress
I have made exactly Zoop
ah you want tangle buddy you want to go
you want to go [ __ ] you want to go huh
what okay we're going okay we're going
never mind didn't think you actually
wanted to go my bad yeah my vision is
permanently tunnel-visioned the field of
view went crazy up in my mouse is slow I
am about to die I am literally god
damnit you shut your mouth even if you
don't have one I don't care you shot it
you shot whatever hole is nearest to
your face wait a minute what was that
is that a map is that a map Peru are you
serious are you serious right now
are you serious is that really what you
think is that a smiley face with two X's
on it really I've gotten so many notes
and made so little progress that I got a
paper with a smiley face with two X's on
it screw you I don't even care anymore I
don't even care I'm about to fall over
and die I haven't found a ding dong damn
thing you go after yourself in the a and
have a lovely day yes let's walk towards
the diabolical sounds of death and not
follows whatever that arrow was always
pointing me in the wrong way oh let's
see what other thing we've got it
listens hard for it listen to this
you're a dick
you're a douchey dong fu oh good for me
I found this right now right now I found
this when I'm about to die and I bet I
just bet ah screw you go to hell I bet
that all good good is on coming death
this is my demise through you hate it
hate it CAD fine ah can't wait I can't
do it I can't wait anymore ain't having
it and you can only run for like two
feet at a time how about you get off
your stupid butt and you start working
for once you're a sewer worker Wayne
Brady sang a song about you oh come on
oh shut the F up you dog crap oh crap oh
god I hate it so much I can't win shut
up oh god you guys haven't seen but I've
been wandering around for just like half
an hour I've been just wandering and it
keeps giving me these obscure clues like
follow the pipes and I try to look for
clues but the pipes are exactly the same
no matter
why ah piss oh this doesn't help me oh
this doesn't LV
doei you're an [ __ ]
good know why crash okay well that's it
you know what that's it I am literally
all that time I can't record anymore I
guess I lost my bed well I'm quitting
YouTube now that was a good run
everybody hope you had fun these two
years little lesson boy I guess the
fun's over
though thanks everybody for watching
permanently I'm gonna go jump off of a
bridge so been fun
I'm bye forever
I'm not really quitting YouTube it was a
joke BAE